hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream qna segment 120th
edition
and um we survived the winter
we did survive the winter yep it is so
springy out there it's beautiful yes it
is yeah um all right let's just jump
right into it sure uh we we
we ran long we'll we'll keep this
shortish but uh just a reminder you can
ask questions at
i have no idea uh
darkhorsesubmissions.com
www.darkwaysubmissions.com
i have no questions
you always have questions
i sometimes have questions yeah
this from um you get access to the dark
horse discord um community uh and soon
we are gonna have a new a brand new kind
of community on offer uh for people uh
that will be
um
anti-fragile no that's not the right
word i mean it will be anti-fragile but
it will be
robust robust to censorship in a way
that the big tech platforms aren't but
for now
uh the community is on discord and every
week
some of them
pose questions and then they vote on
them and the highest ranked question
is what we start the q a with so this
week it is does evolutionary theory
predict that the woke will win the
culture war because they are willing to
resort to ruthlessness and riling up the
masses to a degree that the opposition
would not
um depends what you mean by when
i do think there is a way in which
uh a coalition
is liable to re-evolve
that actually uh
meritocracy and i'm not suggesting that
we have a meritocracy but we have a
meritocratic thread
in our economic system and our political
system
and it creates
people who are not on the winning side
who will inevitably form a coalition but
the coalition is unstable
and so the point is as they win they
will tear themselves apart and we have
seen this the left eats its own
and
uh we have been them in fact
and so
the prediction is yes they will
uh beat expectations
but in the end their fate is sealed and
the problem is it leaves the door open
for the rent seeking elites to fill the
power vacuum that will
and how yes as if the rent seeking
elites had any trouble getting power
yeah but they're moving right in they're
just uh they're gonna they're gonna
create a
a new thing having created a old thing
that turned out to be fragile and
full of gaping holes both uh
truly and logistically and
intellectually and uh
you know it worked so badly the first
time let's go for a second round but you
can actually i was thinking about saying
something in the uh the main discussion
about this but
you can see
their their
their ploy
in these
symbolic nominations
and i'm not arguing
in the case of the current nominee for
supreme court she's obviously qualified
but the pretense was made
that she was the most qualified person
when before her nomination was announced
in fact during the campaign biden said
he would nominate a
uh
in fact that's one of the questions here
um which is more of a comment might as
well yeah address it um considering that
biden explicitly stated that he was
going to nominate a black woman to the
court being a woman is one of the
characteristics that qualified her for
the nomination being unable to define
the term should have disc disqualified
her then and there
your point it's yeah and i was i was
thinking about this specifically you
know i think she's she's clearly
qualified you know she has the
qualifications there's just no there's
you know there's just no questioning
that
um but there are a lot of people who are
clearly qualified and the fact is that
biden was like oh wow how will i choose
well i'm going to start with two mutable
characteristics
and and thus limit and limit the place
and frankly um katanji brown jackson
appears to be so
so qualified um that if i were her i
would be
upset
that i was there following him saying
that he was going to nominate a black
woman because clearly some number of
people will always think that she is
there because she's a black woman
and
she might well have won on her merits
well in fact she won
is going to win presumably on her merits
having been given a handicap to begin
with
let's let's do this carefully okay
she is obviously qualified
biden announced that he had found the
most qualified candidate
i didn't know that he had said that he
did okay and actually it set off jordan
peterson who
said something on twitter that got him
in some hot water what he said was
exactly right which is that having
announced in advance
these characteristics the likelihood
that she is the most qualified candidate
is low
um might be
right exactly but the basic point is
look you you eliminated anybody who
wasn't female and wasn't black and so
assuming that qualification is equally
distributed across populations which
frankly is unlikely not because of
inherent differences between people but
because histories of oppression mean
that
differential access to the things that
make you qualified is a real phenomenon
even still
so
having set out those characteristics
um
biden presumably doesn't even know if he
found the most qualified candidate
uh and we know that there is a history
we don't know but we can surmise that
there's a history in this administration
of prioritizing symbolism over
qualification
right so we have what could you possibly
be talking about i could be talking
about rachel levine who
might be the most qualified person for
the assistant secretary of health
position that she got i don't think so
let's just say it was pretty clear that
the nomination was about something else
it was about
prioritizing symbolism over
something else we can say the same thing
about the appointment of
sam brenton to be the
head of nuclear waste disposal at the
department of energy which i must tell
you is going to sound to lots of people
like that's a
mundane job
it is anything but
we talked about this at some length a
couple episodes ago
i know but i think people do not fully
appreciate
how much is at stake in the way we
deal with nuclear waste and so for
example you need a candidate who
understands candidate for that job who
understands
the importance to the future of humanity
of getting all nuclear waste that is
cool enough to move out of the cooling
pools and into dry cask storage to get
it out of this state where it requires
constant vigilance to keep it cool
enough not not to catch fire right um
right
and so
in any case the fact that in the middle
of a pandemic
biden made a symbolic appointment to the
assistant secretary of health position
and with a
who then went on to win someone's woman
of the year
which is it was usa today and she at the
same time won the babylon bees man of
the year
which is what got tucker carlson
suspended from twitter for
did he retweet the babylon bay or
something well he retweeted uh kyle no
it was a charlie kirk okay who basically
described
rachel levine's having lived as a man
produced a family etcetera before
transitioning father of several children
right
and father
and contributed sperm to those children
right father of those children so
charlie kirk made that point
yeah you wanna you wanna put up uh
all right we are uh waiting for zach to
be father of children woman of the year
all right
at any moment zach is going to bring up
the tweet that got tucker carlson
suspended from
i'm very excited i've never seen this
i'm so i'm it's really on the edge of my
seat uh that's really it's very tiny
okay
okay
he says i guess almost no one just
listens to this but um he says
oh uh but wait both these tweets are
true and he's referencing charlie kirk's
tweet here richard levine spent 54 years
of his life as a man he had a wife and a
family he transitioned to being a woman
in 2011. joe biden appointed levine to
be a four-star admiral and now usa today
has named rachel levine as a woman of
the year where are the feminists
yeah it's it's actually one of the
things we have not talked about is
um
i'm not shocked but it is noteworthy
that
most of the p so the people who are
benefiting from this the trans activist
i'm not like not talking about the legit
trans people who are trying to live
their damned lives with some
with some dignity and privacy
of which there are
many some of whom we know
um but
this is mostly um men
declaring themselves women and walking
into women's spaces and taking some of
the hard run one rights of women and
that would look like a patriarchal move
if ever there was one but who mostly is
defending these people
it's women
it's it's mostly middle-class women who
are defending these people and saying
that if you don't you're an ist you're
whatever kind of ass who freaking knows
but it's both not surprising and so
disheartening you know there are a lot
of feminists mostly people who call
themselves radfems radical feminists who
are saying no way no how and you know
that's right
i feel that
what what i understand of the history of
of rad fams of radical feminists is that
it is um too agnostic on the biology
that it that understands sex but it
doesn't understand the downstream stuff
of of gender being tied together and
being evolutionary and being not nearly
as much your fate as your sex but that
it's still it's still relevant to your
sex and you can be gender non-conforming
all you want
but that doesn't mean there's not an
evolutionary component
but the rad fams are completely right on
the trans activism stuff and yet so many
other women who
would have been five or ten years ago
talking about the glass ceiling and
really hoping for more female
representation on the court for instance
or you know first female president
are cheering this on and it's it's bad
for everyone but it's obviously bad for
women yeah i mean rachel levine gets
woman of the year right what the actual
it's obviously bad for women and
the other thing is that the willingness
to make symbolic appointments to
positions that actually matter right
like you know
we've got a pandemic with a dangerous
virus yeah okay
to appoint a symbolic person to the job
of assistant secretary for health at
such a moment is to effectively say look
it doesn't really matter who's in the
position as long as they're above some
threshold of qualification
same thing you could say for
sam brenton and the nuclear waste
question now in the case of uh katanji
brand jackson katanji brown jackson
[Music]
you know we are dealing with somebody
who's very qualified but again right
what rests on this yeah it's different
right
it's it's it's different
in that
she appears to actually have the the
qualifications
i i'm not even sure that that's what
makes it different because
the problem is there too so we've got
assistant secretary of health the person
in charge of nuclear waste disposal yeah
and a candidate for supreme court seat
in the middle of an era where the most
important issues are being adjudicated
right like free speech is
um
uh
in jeopardy as a result of novel
environments
so the point is they're really saying
qualified enough
above a certain threshold it doesn't
matter
in all of these cases it matters
dramatically right
from the point of view of having a court
that can protect the rights of a
population including
uh women of color
right you need as qualified a person as
you can get and even that may not be
sufficient and so the idea that you
would limit the categories to do
something symbolic rather than figure
out all right this is an era in which a
great deal is at stake
you know
we need to find the best person and and
what actually makes it different is that
we need the best person for the job and
that means in part
understanding
the different ways that problems show up
and figuring out how to actually think
through lots of steps right and not just
being able to say well i've got this
wealth of knowledge because of my
education and therefore if you tell me
what i need to do right here in a very
limited way then i can do it and then i
can do this that's not a smarter wise
person although they may well have
gotten all the accolades and the grades
at school and there is another danger
here which is that when at the very top
we are modeling the behavior of using uh
demographic considerations to figure out
who's qualified that that
may actually be mirrored all the way
down the line right and so the question
of you know all right sam brinton
took the relevant courses right
did he did he do actually well or did
the same characteristics that caused him
to be appointed to his position caused
him to get a pass in those classes and
i'm not saying
he didn't do well in them i'm saying we
don't know because there is now this
instinct to take people with certain
demographic characteristics and declare
them qualified whether they are or not
right and we i mean we we know we know
of cases individual cases of this having
happened for instance at evergreen we
are still there right you know dean's
coming to faculty and saying why did you
write such and such a narrative
evaluation of this student well because
that's how they did in this class was
like this never happened to us
um but um so in classes that really were
really were very quantitative in nature
and um you know you can argue that test
questions are unfair this thought
they're either right but um you know
it's it's it's one thing in an english
class right it's it can be very hard to
figure out what the assessment's
supposed to look like and you can have a
real sense of like that's not the great
he should have gotten
um and sometimes you're gonna be right
and i've certainly seen cases like that
um but in a class in which there are
tests that everyone is taking and there
isn't a hue and cry about like that does
was ridiculous you know the the quest
the answers were wrong or it had nothing
to do with what we learned or you taught
us the opposite or whatever right like
in a class where
the vast majority of people were like
yeah that was fair and yeah i didn't do
as well as i could have but that's on me
um when
you have administration coming to
faculty saying that person needs to get
a better assessment well but they didn't
do better right well but that person
you've seen the color of their skin
haven't you they need to be given a
better assessment that is
anti-meritocratic anti-intellectual
anti-democratic anti-everything we
should be caring about we know that's
happening at least at one little pod
experimental college in the pacific
northwest and we have heard stories of
it happening in lots of other places as
well so you know that that is the end of
education of being able to tell anything
about
what a person can do based on
transcripts and of course we know this
to be the case yeah there's that and
it's of course doing no favor to people
who are are benefiting from especially
if you can get all the way through the
system on the basis that you deserve to
pass rather than you earned it right um
and you know so
it's not that it's a simple problem to
solve but it's a problem you have to
solve and at the point that we're
putting important things like how
nuclear waste is going to be disposed of
or how we're to deal with the pandemic
or how we're going to navigate the
question of
of freedom of speech in
2022
these are
vital roles and you know again the most
qualified person might not be good
enough for the job taking anything less
is insane exactly
all right oh my god my computer is
flipping out on me here um
next question
uh i am reading ian mcgilchrist's new
master work the matter with things i
think this i think i heard this is like
a 3 000 page tome it's incredible maybe
that's a different book but that sounds
like miguel crystal
he's written another amazing book
and he surfaces coherence
logic
correspondence and consensus as
components which in the then overlay
middle
which in the then overlay middle
constitute shared reality
sophistry is coherent and can achieve
various percentage of consensus but no
correspondence with physical data
love you both
yeah that's good yeah
that is good um and that may be its
hallmark
is that it is the sub this softest not
yeah yeah
yeah i like that so uh we haven't we
haven't even seen this book yet but so
he it's got mcgillcrest talking about
coherence logic correspondence and
consensus
um
that um
you have shared reality when
correspondence coherence and consensus
all meet up um
substitute being coherent and they can
have consensus but no correspondence
with physical data yeah it's good
it sure is
next
have you heard of dean wiggington
or reviewed geoengineeringwatch.org
he talks about the missing insects issue
that brett mentioned recently with chris
martinson as being a potential
consequence of climate engineering
given the grave consequences were such
operations ongoing do you think it's
worth investigating
i don't know anything about i've never
heard of this guy or this site
geoengineeringwatch.org do you know
anything about i don't i'm
curious about anything that contributes
um my instinct is
uh
pesticides are probably the leading
issue yeah um but yeah i would be i
would be up for understanding
uh any contributing factor and it really
it does suggest quite an emergency
yep uh well i've pulled up the site but
it's too there's too much to assess
right in the moment so so what do they
mean geo engineering though well i mean
you can show if you want zac whatever so
i've just pulled it up this is the first
time i've ever been on the site i'm um
engineering wildfires creating storms
jet spraying tree die off runaway
methane society
scenario rather let's let's see what
engineering wildfires means
the climate engineering cabal has
relentlessly
cut the flow of moisture into much of
the u.s west
ionosphere heater-induced high-pressure
heat domes and constant jet-spread
aerosol dispersions are core to the
equation i am doubtful about this yeah i
don't know
i don't know
um
yeah
i
let's put it this way i'm open to
anything that is evidence-based and
plausible
but
i think there's a lot of discussion
about potentially engineering climate i
don't know that
much is taking place yeah and with
regard to
the massive insect iaf which is
empirically demonstrated
and which
you know ev every line of thinking tells
you that as that happens then so too
will fall all the insectivorous
creatures then so too will follow all
the you know carnivorous on insects
creatures than you know everything every
everything will fall
um and
you don't need
geo-engineering to explain the insect
die-off right um
that's not to say it's not possible but
you don't need it as an explanatory
factor yep
okay
when you went to evergreen was it clear
to you that you wanted to teach that you
had it in you to teach that you had
something worth teaching and how you
wanted to teach
well that's a book length question isn't
it
yeah um
i'll start
i
got an offer at evergreen at the same
time that i got an offer at another
school at a private liberal arts college
so lucky to get two to tenure track
faculty offers at the same time
and i had applied to them
because um
yes i thought that what i wanted to do
was
combine research with education and not
be pretending to educate and only be
allowed access to students in the way
that most faculty at r1
universities and big research
universities have
both brett and i as graduate students
in order to pay our way through graduate
school
were
you were given as all
u of m biology phd students were at the
time
i think it was like five years ten
semesters worth of uh ta-ing
so
we had
done
several i guess we both did all ten of
our semesters
of ta-ing and
boy the first time i think my first i
think my first teaching at michigan was
or the second semester of intro bio
and i got up in front of a bunch of
mostly pre-meds and pre-dentists and you
know pre-nursing pre-health kids
and just thought i'd do this i have no
interest in being in front of people i
wanna i wanna go
work with animals in the rainforest and
then write privately and never be in
front of an audience at all
and it turns out that there was just so
much to be done and the the brains of
the undergrads to whom i was very close
in age at that point
were extraordinary and it was just a
really
easy way to meet a whole lot of new
people's approaches to the world and
help them upgrade what it is that they
sensed about the world and how they made
sense of it
so i kind of fell in love with it much
to my surprise
did i think uh
that i had something worth teaching yeah
um by then i i was i was certain of it
and um how you wanted to teach that's
something that although both brett and i
did you know tade
at ever at michigan and i had also done
by the time i got the evergreen job i'd
done a study abroad course with an
independent outfit in panama for a month
that i that i loved tropical animal
behavior class
and
i had a sense from that of how you could
teach when you weren't constrained by
being underneath a faculty member who
said okay you have to do these you know
these discussion sections and this and
this and this so i had some ideas and
you had some ideas and we both benefited
from knowing each other and having had
wildly different experiences in
classrooms ourselves in school ourselves
but
both of us were floored were really
surprised by how much you could do with
a model that was evergreens that allowed
faculty full freedom and so that was the
thing
uh how you wanted to teach i had some
ideas but i couldn't even begin to
imagine before i had been doing it for a
little bit what all was possible
yeah uh that covers a lot of what i
would say i believe i
knew
hey zach
i believe i knew that i had something
worth teaching
and i knew from teaching at michigan as
a graduate student that i could do it i
also knew that i was going to have
trouble
as you
ascend the academic ladder you have to
do a lot of teaching that is from a
textbook effectively
you know teaching of courses that the
the university wants taught and teaching
the received wisdom right yeah and i was
gonna have a very hard time with that
and i will say that my first
job at evergreen
they had a
lack of a faculty
member or a la they needed a faculty
member to teach science and they said
can you do it and
i was excited and they said write a
proposal and i was a little floored that
i could write any proposal that i wanted
but i did i wrote the craziest thing i
could think of
um
which uh what was it what was the first
program first program was adaptation the
study of organisms mechanisms and ideas
and the idea was that these were
parallel things and
i thought it was going to be rejected
because it was too far out there and it
wasn't and then i had 25
maybe it was 30 students show up
and
i was suddenly liberated to do anything
i wanted and i just
started leading them through this thing
and it turned into as a very good group
of students
and we went on some good field trips and
anyway um
you know it was
uh it was a very very good first
experience and that
program evolved into sort of my flagship
adaptation program which i continued
for my whole 14 years at evergreen
but
it was clear from that moment that if
you took off the constraints
that there was a tremendous amount to be
done that it was very very rewarding
work
and um that you know
that i could figure out what to do with
it yeah
um
you know there's something that i'd
never quite put together listening to
you um talk about it
you got hired as a as a visitor at first
and you
were given all of the freedom right up
front right up front because they didn't
they weren't slotting you into someone
else's program you you did do some of
that later on
but i who had been hired as you know
the way that you want to be hired right
the way that you dream about being hired
was slotted into teaching freshwater
ecology yep
and i was like i don't know anything
about freshwater rhetoricology this is
really not what i do i've never even
never lived in the pacific northwest
before you want me to teach about
macroinvertebrate and stream ecology and
like water stuff and like i had
i had done some water chemistry as some
part of my phd just of these these
little fighter tomatoes
the frogs lived in but that was about it
like this was just not my scene at all
and i was able to turn it to some degree
but that was the first two quarters
teaching at evergreen and i was like oh
this isn't nearly as expansive and
amazing as i was expecting and then i
got to do my own animal behavior program
that i got to design entirely from
scratch in the spring of that year like
ah here we go
yeah well two things show up in the
story that are important one
evergreen
heather and i sometimes say evergreen um
they the founders broke every
rule
and
half the ways that they broke those
rules were brilliant and half of it
didn't work out and the problem with
evergreen is that nobody ever went and
fixed the stuff that didn't work the
stuff the stuff that they broke uh
productively was great
one of the things that they broke
productively
was
they eliminated faculty rank
right and so the idea was i did have
even as a visitor i had full rights as a
faculty member as long as they kept
rehiring me that's right and i be my
nature was such that i took advantage of
it you know in a good way that can sound
like you took advantage of consistently
behaved like a full faculty member
the way evergreen did it that was stupid
was they never gave you a title that
made sense to anybody who wasn't there
though in order to break
the uh the faculty rank problem that
exists at other colleges which they
successfully did
they decided everybody was going to be a
member of the faculty which makes you
sound like you're
lower than an adjunct yeah right and
that was very destructive
um so anyway it was one of these cases
where you could easily have fixed that
problem you could have just said okay
you're a professor whether you're
visitor or or not but
but
in your case
they had an on-boarding mechanism
because it was a little because not
giving you any
help to figure out what to do with the
liberty that a evergreen professor has
they had an onboarding process which
served you badly because they slotted
you into teaching something that wasn't
your thing right right and you would
have had no trouble figuring out what to
do if they just said you know hey name
your course and you teach it which is
what they did with me because in my case
they
were facing not enough professors and
they would yeah they just needed um they
had a bunch of students who were gonna
who needed who wanted to do upper
division science they knew that they had
this need for upper division science
seats
and they're like just do do something
that's upper division do something try
not to embarrass us and the point was it
worked so well you evergreen trying to
embarrass us right well that's the thing
is they were ready to accept something
lackluster if it gave students somewhere
to go and some sort of productivity in
my case they gave me exactly what i
needed which was total freedom to figure
out what to teach and how to teach it
and
that resulted in you know i quickly
started to build a reputation and then
my classes were always overflowing and
they got sort of addicted to rehiring me
because it took care of a lot of
students who wanted somewhere to go and
i would have some bonus they were
actually getting educated right so not
just accruing credits
so anyway it's funny uh you would have
been better off in my situation even
though it was you know i definitely
came in through the skylight rather than
the front door
that's right
yeah that's right all right next
question
have either of you read atlas shrugged
thoughts
you know i haven't um back in high
school my parents were like
you probably should read some anne rand
at some point and i just i didn't i read
a lot of stuff but i'd never i didn't
i haven't i have i have shrugged off
ann rand um and yes i should probably
have uh have read a bit but
oh boy um
i'm gonna this is written a little bit
telegraphically so i'm gonna expand it a
little bit uh
my son is applying to post-secondary
school
facts free
i like that construction facts free
facts free and not sure what he wants to
study he kept all sciences and maths
which i think means that he took them
all
um
so this must be in canada with the new
ontario bill 67 and mandatory vacs i
don't know what to suggest to him so
there was another
excuse me there was another question
about
i thought there was another question
about
ontario bill 67
maybe not but i have it i had not heard
of it have you heard of it no it is
here we go and you can show my screen if
you want sec
uh bill 67 racial equity in the
education system act 2022.
uh
some of the highlights are
the minister will direct a board to
develop its anti-racism accountability
report if in the opinion of the minister
there's indication the board's new
teacher induction program does not
include anti-racism and racial equity
training
um
we have the ministry of training
colleges and universities act which
already existed i i was hoping that was
a new orwellian thing but that already
existed is amended to add a new section
1 17.1 which sets out anti-racism and
racial equity requirements that apply to
every college of applied arts and
technology and every university that
receives ongoing operating funds from
the government for the purposes of
post-secondary education
and on and on and on i have not read the
whole thing but uh you get the gist yes
so um this mother
has a son thinking about college doing
some science and math doing a lot of
science and math
who is both um
non-compliant with regard to the coveted
vaccine mandates and
seeing this
what was it bill bill 67 the racial
equity in the education system act
coming down and going
what do i do
so i i don't quite understand something
the mandate requires
this person to be vaccinated to go
at this point i think it does and so you
know that's obvious that just stops like
bill 67 is irrelevant um as awful as it
is uh because uh mandatory vac stops
that on the other hand there is talk of
canada lifting some of its draconian
vaccine mandate measures
well then i guess i'll just
i mean you know
i don't want to give anybody medical
advice but i gotta tell you
for me i wouldn't allow i wouldn't be
persuaded by
uh limits on what i was allowed to do
um there's a danger for young people
here young men in particular yeah young
men in particular
so
there's that and that may answer the
question right there
as for what to do if it doesn't answer
the question
increasingly
it is hard to justify on the merits of
what one will learn
the presence in
these environments they're actively
miseducating and so
it's a racket
that racket
has something to do with whether or not
you'll be able to get a job
and
let's not pretend it's anything other
than a racket
and maybe that answers the question
maybe the point is should i pay
protection well
no in principle you should not pay
protection
do you need to pay protection maybe you
do and maybe that's how you'll run your
business and this is that same thing
it's a racket should you participate in
the racket in what way would it be good
to participate in an educational racket
what would be the most educational thing
you could take at an institution that
was that was determined not to educate
you
i don't know that that question has an
answer
but as you have pointed out here before
this racket uh went global both of these
rackets uh well the the
the racial equity thing you know bill 67
is particular to i guess ontario not
even all of canada
but it spread throughout the west uh i
don't know that
it's spread
it you know higher ed in india but i
also don't know if a canadian kid
interested in science and math if it
makes sense to consider going to college
in india for instance and i just came up
with india because they're strong in
science and math
but
you used to be in the before times
if the problem was
boy
don't know if that's going to be
educational but uh probably do want to
get a formal education but maybe let it
settle a little bit travel like if you
travel for a year or two and like
actually really travel and
you know do woofing or do like do any
number of things where you actually just
get to engage with the local people in
the local culture and the local
everything
well that's of course much more
difficult now as well so
uh
it's it's hard to know what to do and
you know we've got
we've got an awesome young man who's
going to be graduating from high school
here soon as well who is in a similar
position with all the sciences and maths
and
we don't have ontario bill 67 here but
we got a lot of stupid and
we
have
a lot of schools that are requiring uh
vacs for uh for enrollment as well
so maybe i can say what i actually think
that's a great idea
mostly
i mean
i'm sorry it's not a simple thing to do
here but um
i don't think these institutions are in
any way worth it and the fact that they
are
anti-educating
is the answer to the question whether
you have the wherewithal to stare down
the
relic that is the requirement that you
have a college education in order to be
a participant in polite society or
whatever
i don't know if you have the ability to
stare it down i don't know if we have
the ability to stare it down but do i
think there's a justification for
wasting four years of your life
in order to get that piece of paper i do
not i don't think you will end up
smarter and the best thing you can do
is probably figure out how to educate
yourself because the resources to learn
virtually anything you want to learn are
out there and so really do you need the
motivational structure of this
institution in order to engage those
materials productively or can you
self-motivate
well and it's you know there
there's a social argument to be made
just like there is for k-12 school
right
that you meet you meet the people with
whom you will make the rest of your
lives
that said
there are
a couple three
uh
alternatives to hey zach
um
thank you
traditional college
that are emerging now that may
may
reveal
some of the ways to move forward and
i'll i'll just name the three of them
here and maybe we'll talk more about
about some of them later one of them is
university of austin which we've talked
about before
one of them is ralston college in
savannah georgia
and one of them is uh entirely online
at this point and it's not even launched
yet in fact they're all nascent
but is peterson academy
and each of these jordan jordan
peterson's
virtual
virtual institution of higher ed if you
will that's going to be launching in
september
and all of these
have approaches have seen at least part
of the problem and i think all of them
have seen a lot of the problem
and
are looking to
with the recognition that a society as
large as the west if you will
needs
a
functional higher ed in order to help
young people
become able to do what they need to do
in the world not all young people but
many of them
how can we uh how can we deal with the
fact that our institutions
if they haven't completely failed which
some of them have are actively failing
and seem intent on continuing to do so
well each of these three new initiatives
uh does provide some hope yep
next question how about separating
biological sex and psychological sex
biological sex would be fixed and
psychological sex would be fluid
everybody wins pronouns based on
psychological sex and sports teams based
on biological sex
nope
we have a word for that we got sex and
we got gender
yeah i'm not sure that doesn't describe
the way the world was
10 years ago
right
biological sex which i don't think is
the right term because
um
psychological sex is biological
but genetic sex
which yes you can
make arguments about
ambiguities but genetic sex
uh determines what prison you go to it
determines what sports you can
participate in you more or less are and
have been free
to reorganize your behavior however you
want
um certainly we had the experience of
lots of students who were trans who
asked us to
you know i never once was asked nor
would i have agreed to somebody's made
up pronouns or they but i was asked to
call call me she or
whatever and i would certainly do that
yep as a matter of courtesy and human
decency and so i think the thing is that
that description there is how it was
right it wasn't like anybody was telling
you you couldn't transition right or
that
um you know
for most of us we wouldn't insist on
calling somebody who presented as female
male because we knew something about
their chromosomes right so but this i
mean this reminds this argument reminds
me of
trans women are women
no
women is a category
trans woman
is
a new category
that we can
most of us
can recognize as being a thing
but
this is not the place for polite
fictions
trans women are not women trans women
are trans women well women are women i
agree with that but i think the point
and we've covered this before is for any
purpose
where you're not
treading on someone else's rights
as a matter of courtesy and decency sure
if you i'm not no i mean pronouns is one
thing
but but
the sentence trans women are women is
just
false is that in there no you you seem
to have objected to what i just said
which is i think but i think you're
imposing something on the question the
question for so this strikes me as
exactly analogous to like well sex okay
why don't we just say well there's
biological sex or psychological sex
it's like well that's like saying well
there's there's women there's cis women
there's trans women no there's women
and then there's this other category
okay
and those are men
who feel strongly the ones who are
honest that they are women
and they're not
but they have done what they can to
present the world as women and we can be
respectful of that when it does not
impinge on other people's rights but
they are not women
and i am not a cis woman i'm a woman
right so sex is sex
psychological sex which follows which is
downstream of sex
is also now has looser boundaries and
it's about you know also um how you
present and what your interests are and
whether or not you're gender
non-conforming and that's that's a
gender thing right but
i think what the question is getting at
is
those places where we're not
running up against the facts or
providing rights to some people and
thereby eliminating rights that other
people are entitled to my feeling is for
all of those purposes you know how do i
treat a trans woman right i treat that
person as a woman at the point that she
shows up to sign up for
um
you know a sport
i stop that
right at the point that she's convicted
of a crime and the question of which
prison she should go to comes up
that's not where i am but my point is
i do believe that we should provide
people
the right to self-define
for and i hesitate to say all practical
purposes but the basic point is all
purposes where you don't force us into
a
scientific fiction
or into damaging somebody's rights well
but i guess that second category
is inherently messy right uh so i was
actually i was listening to a
conversation that uh the wonderful
dr debra so was having on her podcast
with a woman who unfortunately was name
i forgotten
um but she is she has created she she's
a rat femme and she and deborah agree on
a lot but disagree on some things and it
was
i'm sorry this is off the top of my head
i don't remember the woman's name
um but deborah
whom we're friends with
um
was was was making the argument that
uh actually
uh
a trans woman
presenting
as a woman walking into a man's bathroom
is uh going to cause much more
disruption in various people's lives
including her own
um than if she were to walk into a
woman's bathroom and her interlocutor
well i guess it's sort of the opposite
so the guest that she had on her podcast
was saying no zero tolerance because um
you know that's a man which they both
agreed on that's a man who's presenting
as a woman and uh and
no woman should ever have to expect that
there will be a man in a bathroom that
has been advertised as a female only
space i
see the wisdom in both arguments
and obviously there are some bathrooms
where i'm you know if it's a single
occupancy bathroom there's no reason
maybe there's a reason to still have it
be sexed because
men are messier about things um but
maybe it just doesn't matter
in a bathroom with a row of urinals and
stalls that have you know that start
high and end low
i don't think so no and in fact we had a
workspace that had just a gender-neutral
bathroom on one floor and um
and sex bathrooms on the next floor and
our office was on the sex neutral the
gender-neutral bathroom floor and i
never used it i used it once like i
don't like this i don't like this
uh
and it wasn't you know it wasn't a trans
woman it's not like i don't feel like
peeing next to a dude that i don't know
i don't feel like having my pants down
next to a strange man right right
so
there are you know there are arguments
on sort of the
on one side
which
people like rad films will make that say
slippery slope no just no never and then
you know
far over on this side
are stupid arguments which we're never
gonna you know agree to you know
whatever you think at whatever moment
you just go into that space
but
over here there's a lot to actually talk
about and i do worry
that
um you know give them an inch they take
a mile
and once you give up a space
you know
girls in schools are apparently just not
using bathrooms where now you've got
gender neutral right bathrooms
like girls are learning to give
themselves urinary tract infections and
that's probably the least of it i think
the problem is this is a not solvable
problem that the solution to this
problem is individual bathrooms
right and maybe that's a solution that
has to happen anyway maybe it should
happen for other reasons i don't know
but the problem is
you know there's an argument to be made
for parsing it as
people who are capable of rape do not
belong in a woman's bathroom right so
it's a question of like physical
plumbing
of the person that is
um
there's an argument to be made
that those spaces were about attraction
right and therefore
you know
what do you do
you know
so the point is it's not solvable
are you going to exclude gay people
because they might be attracted to
people in the same bathroom and those
are supposed to be non-sexual spaces
no we obviously don't do that
um so
i think you have an unsolvable problem
unlike sports and unlike prisons
and
well
at the point that you appear to have an
unsolvable problem
and there is a tiny percentage of the
population and there is half the
population who might be at risk with one
or the other decision
then it seems you have to go with the
decision that protects half the
population i agree but protects them
from what i mean
let's suppose you have a trans man who
presents as
a man
what bathroom does he go into
well i mean
in that case
his
presenting
is
his preferred bathroom
going in there might be the thing that
gets him
beat up right but
he's you know as you say you see the
wisdom in both points which basically
means this is an unsolvable problem i'm
not i'm not sure what point you just you
just made
um
the trans man is a woman
right presenting as a man going into a
woman's bathroom
okay but
there are a few exceptions
very few
but trans men
largely don't pass
right
but
i mean you know i i think i'm i'm just
at the point of i don't think there's a
solution to this problem that is simply
a right solution i think every solution
that you would come up with causes
problems and so ultimately what we will
do and must do
is define bathrooms in such a way that
this is no longer an issue because
otherwise we're going to continue to
tear ourselves apart over
you know whichever failure mode we've
chosen
yeah i don't i mean i don't think that's
going to happen at the societal level at
the sort of infrastructure level in
which case
catering to the needs of a
tiny minority
isn't
isn't what we do
that's where i fall out
um
you talked about this on earlier next
question you talked about this in an
earlier podcast religion focuses on evil
within the person
cults focus on evil outside the group
heard it on jordan peterson podcast
i don't think there's a question there
but
yeah i'm not sure
i'm not sure i buy that distinction yeah
it seems to me that religions
uh often define an evil outside
precisely they're tribal yeah
i mean exactly so
yeah
um
oh this here it is bill 67 in canada is
horrifying could it happen here what can
we do
yeah could happen here
absolutely yep what can we do
what can we do brett
well
first i would think we would need to
come up with some sort of a public
square where we could actually have a
conversation about the hazard that these
things pose let's call it sam's dab all
right let's try that awesome till we
come up with a better name
i think that's a good name you don't
like it um wait you know where you can
write you can write into uh yeah
stop being a nerd at samusdap.com all
right
okay
um
what is the evolutionary role
of suicide and why does it feel like it
and more has been weaponized in
modernity also pet the epic tabby
yeah he's sweepy
he's sleepy today
um
let's put it this way suicide becomes a
not very difficult
evolutionary puzzle once you understand
lineage
i will tell you that my friend david
lottie and i
filed a
abstract give a talk
on the question of how suicide could be
explained evolutionarily and it was the
only time i've ever even heard of this
where qualified people submitted a
proposal for a talk at a conference that
was just flat out rejected they didn't
want to hear it yeah um
david lottie who uh the two of you
co-authored your evolution of morality
paper yep which is excellent yeah
but anyway
i will say i think suicide has changed
that modernity has caused something to
be triggered in people where suicide
makes no sense but it doesn't mean that
evolutionary sense is hard to see
um
once you understand that lineages are an
actual focus of evolutionary selection
yeah
very good
um we've been going for an hour haven't
we zack
all right oh i thought it was
okay um
what's up
um
let's do a couple more questions and
then we will then we will stop all right
i don't know what this means but i'll
read it behavior guide selection so
subsequent antigen exposures elicit
second order proliferation
memory regulating like an evolutionary
ratchet can you go back to the beginning
of that question
behavior guides selection
so subsequent antigen exposures elicit
second order proliferation
comma memory regulating like an
evolutionary ratchet question mark
i understand all the words but i think
there are like three different yeah
things being done this is someone who
writes who writes in a lot i i i assume
you got some you're going for something
good but neither of us can make sense of
it as written yeah sorry sorry about
that
the core of many issues is definition
can we put effort into a common argument
depends on for what i mean
yeah
yeah i mean i do think
uh
as i've said
often when people
have generated their own
productive way into
some important puzzle and then they try
to share it with other people who've
done the same
there's a language barrier and often
they don't recognize it because they
forget that they've redefined words in
order to make the glossary work right
it's very important if you're going to
solve problems yourself you do need a
glossary that's consistent
and you forget that the words you're
using are used by others differently
and there's no getting around the phase
where you have to train each other about
this is what i mean you know sympathy
and empathy is when i trip over a lot
because yeah
they needed a fix
but it's not a shared fix yep um but
anyway the
the point is definitions are very
important and we all
suffer from
very blunt definitions that is to say
not sharp
right because
you know we'll pick a word and that word
has some distribution of what people
mean by it and so you say it and it's
heard as some sort of vague cloud when
the person speaking may mean it in some
very precise way
so these things are really important and
they are
fundamental you have to have them in
order to make a precise argument so yes
we are tripping over that all the time
yes
um
i don't know this i will read it
alternative climate science do you know
the suspicious observers youtube channel
by ben davidson
and the questions would you consider
interviewing him given that we don't
know i will just
open up a tab so i can take a look later
but um i will say
there are too many things to look at so
again no
no promises that will actually end up
happening
um
two more questions and then we basically
got through everything there's just a
couple of comments here oh someone wants
to know sam is dap it's
s-a-m-i-z-d-a-p-p
that's how it's spelled right
um
oh modern women reducing investment for
sex are we becoming seahorses
no we talked about that
we went over the seahorses
thing will the left ever again report
anything they don't like male
information indeed
i hope so
uh yeah we need the the left needs to be
resurrected because the left even if
you're on the right the left is an
important force of history and frankly
if you're in its loyal opposition all of
the no even beyond that though
all of the stuff that you on the right
are now defending is the the
product of past radicals who succeeded
so
you need your radicals whether you like
us or not
and um so anyway yes a loony left isn't
good for anybody yeah it's a disaster so
let's let's hope so let's hope that they
do again report things that they don't
like
final question oh we got a few more but
um
final question because i didn't see
these others until just now
were triceratops intersex or were they
just horny
man
it happened
it did
yep
all right well
here we are
here we are here we are with the epic
tabby who you can see just the back of
on a fine saturday afternoon and spring
we hope that wherever you are listening
or watching to this you are able to
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you